Speaker 1: OK, so we did part one of this
wacky Georgia weekend wherein we looked at
Donald Trump's speech at a rally in Commerce
Georgia, but I told you there would be three
parts will eventually get to the rally attendees.
But first, I want to do something intermediate,
which is to look at some of the people on
the stage, some of the other people who participated
in the rally because at very often at these
rallies, we say, you've got the craziness
of Trump and you've got the craziness of the
rally goers.
But here we actually have really in its full
glory, the level of delusion and depravity
of the people that still are willing and interested
in associating themselves with Donald Trump,
including candidates and current elected officials.
And so let's go through some of those.
First and foremost, radical Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene was at the rally.
She spoke at the rally and before speaking,
she was interviewed.
And here she puts together some outrageous
idea that they, if they take the house, will
investigate Hunter Biden's laptop.
Now, Hunter Biden has nothing to do with the
administration.
I don't know why anyone still talking about
his laptop, but take a listen to this
Speaker 5: and they were doing all these shady
business deals in Ukraine and other countries.
What they were doing is investing in bio labs,
interested in bio weapons, and my team is
already looking into it.
And I have to tell you, we had our Republican
retreat for the past couple of days and there's
going to be a new Republican Party coming
back in Washington and we're playing oversight
committees on every single committee.
There will be oversight investigations.
And you better bet Hunter Biden laptop will
be top of the list.
Speaker 1: So there's about four funny things
there.
Number one, there's going to be a new Republican
Party.
If that's true, I don't think she's going
to be part of it.
And what I mean by that is there's increasingly
pressure within the Republican Party to get
the hell away from people like Marjorie Taylor
Greene.
So if there's a new Republican Party, she'll
be gone.
Number two, she talks about all of the things
committees are going to do.
She's been kicked off every committee.
That's also a funny thing.
Now, of course, if Republicans win in the
fall, they may put Marjorie Taylor Greene
back on committees.
That's fair.
But the idea that Hunter Biden's laptop is
going to be a top priority, I don't think
she's kidding.
I think she's telling the truth, and that's
what makes it so scary.
Then she jumped in to the typical anti-Semitic
tropes.
See if you can spot them here,
Speaker 4: some of the topics you're going
to talk about.
Speaker 5: Well, what I'll be talking about
is some of what I've talked about right now,
but I'll also be talking about how there's
the globalist agenda.
And that agenda has been brought forth by
the World Economic Forum, Klaus Schwab and
all of their cronies.
These are the same people that you know.
What they want right now is they want war
and more and more because they love crisis
and they love to use it to their political
advantage now.
Speaker 1: The topics are going to many of
our untrained ears.
You might not recognize anything, she said
is anti-Semitic, and I concede she may not
mean these things in an openly anti-Semitic
way.
But this is the same old trope of globalist
control.
The one guy she mentions is Jewish for the
personal gain of the people doing the controlling.
Often, they say Klaus Schwab and George Soros
globalist is another buzzword.
Sometimes these people don't even realize
that these all of these ideas have a basis
in anti-Semitism, but it's Marjorie Taylor
Greene, and she doesn't realize the origins
of half the things that she says.
Then Matt Gates spoke.
Matt Gates also spoke at the rally, and he
says he wants Trump to be speaker of the House
if Republicans win in November.
Speaker 4: Give us the ability to fire Nancy
Pelosi, take back the majority, impeach Joe
Biden, and I would nominate Donald Trump for
Speaker of the United States House of Representatives.
Unidentified: Thank you very much.
Speaker 4: Well, that was interesting.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now again, I don't think it's going to work
out for them, but there is really a movement
within the Republican Party to make Trump
speaker of the House if they win in November.
Remember that you don't have to be a member
of the House to be speaker of the House.
Anybody can be made speaker of the House.
It's just traditionally it's been a member
of the House.
And then we got to a really ugly phase in
the event, which is when Herschel Walker spoke
Herschel Walker, who recently said if monkeys
still exist, how could evolution be real?
Here he is.
Speaker 4: Listen to this because we're not
black, we're not white.
We're American, we all must.
I hate to tell you that we should have learned
a long time ago that 23 million screwed us
all up.
Speaker 1: That's really the enemy, guys.
23, and me and then Herschel Walker apparently
wanting to talk about CRT critical race theory,
instead talking about S.T.A.R.
Speaker 4: over this country.
People want to ask me all the time while running.
I'm sick and tired.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but I mean, I have no idea
why he's running.
It's a good question.
Speaker 4: I'm sick and tired of didn't want
to teach CPR in school.
Critical race theory.
Can you tell me what that mean?
Speaker 1: We can.
And again, this is a guy who's taken a lot
of hits to the head.
He may have a brain injury.
That's not a joke.
I mean, he played football for a while.
Heisman Trophy winner, College Football Pro
football.
He does seem to often be extraordinarily confused
during these speeches and S.T.A.R.
that's click through rate and add in the world
of advertising.
S.T.A.R.
is a very important metric, and maybe he wants
it taught in school.
And then here is Marjorie Taylor Greene barely
able to see over the lectern going on a very
homophobic rant about Pete Budda judge?
And I'll explain that to you in a moment.
Speaker 5: And you know what people in charge
can take is electric vehicles and is bicycles.
And he and his husband can stay out of our
girls bathrooms.
Speaker 1: That is, man, that is so depressing.
That's standard right wing, homophobic Naderi.
And it's the idea that gay men are pedophiles.
Why would Pete Budda Judge be interested in
hanging out in a girl's bathroom?
It doesn't make any sense.
And of course, the disdain for bicycles.
You don't like bicycles.
You don't like electric vehicles.
Like what is there not to like about an electric
vehicle?
So this is part two of our exploration of
the rally in Georgia.
We looked at the Trump anatomy and now the
acolyte naderi next.
And lastly, no more.
This is the last part.
We will look at the attendees